come here chris
have a little of dabong yeah
here chris
let's go
i deserve this yes you do
[Music]
hey what's going on everybody for first
week feast i'm shawn evans and you're
watching hot ones it's the show with hot
questions and even hotter wings and
today we're joined by leslie mann she's
an actress whose credits include some of
the biggest comedy films of the last 25
years from knocked up to the 40 year old
virgin funny people blockers and many
more her latest project though is the
meta comedy the bubble which is set to
hit netflix on april 1st leslie mann
welcome to the show thank you how are
you around spicy food before we get
started here um so i've had um tabasco
sauce like just a little tiny bit which
is very spicy for me
and cholula sauce which i like on
scrambled eggs
um which i can handle but that's like
pretty lightweight stuff right but you
never know maybe i'll i'll be able to
handle it off that's what we see secret
talent here all along
[Music]
[Music]
so this first one's the classic and
we'll start at the handle over here okay
okay
um
that's what everyone says
[Music]
that's good
like a little tangy
i like it
that's a good one
where's the camera plastic hot sauce
leslie we should get some of this good
house
um
very good okay so your latest comedy of
the bubble is a wry story about a group
of actors trying to complete a
blockbuster film called cliff b6 in the
middle of a global pandemic
in what ways did the challenges of
making cliff b6 mirror the reality of
making the bubble like were there any
jokes or observations that you found to
be especially on the nose in terms of
being self-referential well at the time
we were all in quarantine when judd was
writing the movie
and so we were talking to um actors who
were working on movies and
tv shows and um they were telling us
stories about things that were going on
like being miserable because they had to
go into a tiny hotel room and quarantine
for two weeks
so there were disguises and escapes and
so we kind of like pulled from those
stories
are your eyes watering no not yet it
might just be that might have been too
spicy for you whoa let's go let's go
number two dropping the hamburger
already this next one is the dawson
cedar smoked garlic
hopefully i can handle it
your eyes were watering
it has a bite
what's good though
so when we had paul rudd on the show he
talked about how the movies that he
finds funniest are often categorized as
dramas and that some of the most
dramatic moments in film oftentimes
happen in comedies what do you
personally think of the phrase dramatic
comedy which is often used to describe
some of your most beloved films
i
like to be able to
feel something deeply
and also be able to laugh about it
i've always thought of myself as like a
dramatic actress i don't think of myself
as a comedy actress and on the topic of
paul rudd fact or fiction he improvised
passing gas and that don't fart in the
bed scene and this is 40. hmm
i don't know if he likes to talk about
that
one time i talked about it and um during
an interview and he
he got mad at me so now he's going to
get mad at me again sorry but uh but i
think it's because the person
interviewing us was like he's married to
the most beautiful woman but it happened
to be like this really beautiful woman
and i think i embarrassed him talking
about farts yeah
but yes he did improvise that
yes and it was
not cool
he hot pocketed me
that was not cool
[Music]
i like the garlic and the sun-dried
tomato
that i just sounded like aina garten
to myself
didn't i
i love the cedar smoked garlic and the
hot sauce and the chilies and the
sun-dried tomato mmm and then she eats
it she's so excited do you watch that
show no yeah
aina is a is a legend this is she's a
legend this is a food show and uh you
can't have a food show in the space now
and not pay respect to the legend so
shout out to aina absolutely did you see
the episode where she talks about
um
making brownies for jeffrey no tell me
about making brownies for jeffrey so
she's like when jeffrey and i
met i made him brownies and that was the
key to his heart and then
and then she's like it's our you know
whatever 40th anniversary and i made
jeffrey's his favorite chicken and some
his favorite brownies and then and then
she like presents the food to jeffrey
and he's all excited and he says he has
a surprise for her and he like pitched a
tent because that's what they did when
they were first dating
and so she goes into the tent and he
follows and she peeps her head out and
she says if the tents are rocking don't
come and knock it and then sit down
i can't get that out of my head well i
think about it a lot that is why she's
the legend
okay this is good so far you're crushing
two three four five six seven to go yep
are you ready to move on to the fourth
one yes
whoa
gotta cut job
[Music]
oh
okay
what's on my lips
[Music]
[Laughter]
i'm glad
that one's okay yeah that cooked it up
there we go what's outside oh it has uh
some cantaloupe melon in this one little
sweetness with the heat but
the heat comes through
yeah it does
so you have an amazing quote about rude
casting director saying in a 2009
backstage interview when people are
being [ __ ] you might as well not
waste your time because chances are
they're going to make a piece of [ __ ]
anyway what immediately comes to mind
when you think of the unpleasant or
dismissive auditioning experiences that
inspired that quote i wonder who i was
mad at you must have been fresh off of
something right
oh my gosh but it's true
just like treating actors like dog [ __ ]
like we don't have feelings and we're
not human beings
i wonder what happened that day though
me too something must have happened
um you know just like rude people when
you're trying to put yourself out there
and be open and and do your job
it's nice to have supportive people
around you and not
rude
people
like it with anything
[Music]
i think i'm gonna be fine
i'm halfway through and i'm like it's
okay you're doing good mm-hmm you're
doing good
we'll see how things go in the back half
there's
i think that's way worse
that's the show
okay
but before we get there
lastly we have a recurring segment on
our show called explain that gram we do
a deep dive on our guest instagram pull
interesting pictures that need more
context okay so we'll pull the picture
up over here on the monitor you just
tell us the bigger story
looking back what's the tv or movie set
that made you laugh the most when the
camera is cut probably this one the
other woman yeah i had so much fun with
cameron she's one of my best friends
just honestly being with the girls being
with kate upton and cameron diaz and
we just had so much fun together we
would go out and
and have wine after work and
and it was shot during the summer and it
was warm in new york city it was just
like a dream like a dream job
yeah is this where it gets crazy back
half you look scared
well i love how you just dive
dive right in okay i i like that shoot
first ask questions later you're
struggling more than me
well there we go this one queen majesty
coco ghost
[Music]
hmm
what if i'm just fine with hot sauce
did i speak to you
[Music]
should i be the host of this show you
might be maybe we can trade off like
i'll do some people and you can do some
people i feel like i could yeah
maybe i could do a movie or two and you
know you can do youtube talk show yeah
yeah
i like that okay this one got spicy
was this queen majesty queen majesty
coco ghost i don't taste anything the
cocoa part or the
just the spice yeah the ghost comes
through that's the ghost all ghost
okay
what makes the 1971 hal ash be directed
classic herald and mod a quintessential
comedy for you
i love that
movie um
well it seems like um
maybe
yeah i feel this one now
oh
so
we had a vcr player you probably don't
know what that is no i remember vcr
players i'm a child of the 90s over here
and we had
that movie harold and mod my mom gave it
to us for christmas one year
and then we also had the workout video
by the guy from the richard gere movie
lou gossett jr
so for some reason we had his workout
video and just herald and mud and so
my mother and father
um that was one of their first dates
going to see harold and mod at a move in
a drive-in theater
oh almost as romantic as the tent and
the brownies
exactly
but yeah so it has like history and then
also it was all i had but also
i really loved watching it and i would
cry and feel so be so moved you know by
it's such a great story
and and the music is so beautiful and
the acting is so beautiful and i just i
like i really loved it it kind of like
shaped me in a weird way
thank god she gave me a good movie what
if she gave me a different movie and
that was the thing that shaped me
and then i was like just off for the
rest of my life
or didn't want to pursue acting at all
yeah yeah right yeah what's the big deal
with this why would i ever want to do
that well
shout out to harold and maude yeah are
you ready to move on here to the next
wing yeah this is jekyll and hyde 13
angry scorpions here in the seven spot
oh this is a scary looking bottle
[Music]
it says freakishly hot
[Music]
this one's not that this one's pretty
spicy yeah it it grows it grows
did you have any harrowing encounters
with wildlife on the set of george of
the jungle like what are the mechanics
i'm shooting
that lion rescue scene with bongo and
caesar it's
with bongo and caesar wait is that the
the lions yeah they're famous lions
so yes they put me in with i don't know
which one it was bongo or caesar
so i was in a little tiny space he's
probably like where you are from me
um and so
this one's really spicy yeah and it gets
so much spicier
and so i remember i think about this a
lot because i think
you know
when you hear about animals attacking
um
i think i i don't know why he didn't
attack me and i i mean there's really
nothing you can do when they're that
close if he just jumps at me
i'm dead i just bet that's all right
right and and they didn't have anyone in
between us
just like a man
like where that sign is
away like what's he gonna be able to do
right
and so and i went along with it so i
always tell my daughters
do not
listen to anyone
telling you like if you feel
instinctually feel like something isn't
safe trust your instincts walk away
and like
ask someone smart or you know call me or
[Laughter]
but don't just listen to the movie
people tell you it's safe don't just go
along with it right because you don't
want to like cause a problem like i
shouldn't have done that well you know
what speaking of staring the lion right
in the eyes
this next one is the bomb beyond
insanity oh no
this one's crazy
my god
yeah
oh my god
she's gonna look
right over what
i know
i know
[Music]
who eats that
i don't see a use for it personally
[Music]
i'm about to fall apart
whoa
oh it grows a little bit it grows a
little bit we'll kind of gas pedal to
the finish line here
oh my god
what um how long does it last
oh that's really bad it'll just suck
who's i doing the show you might be in
the room oh my god
not your idea though
no but you know what i ended up as ho
you know like this guy he's just got the
idea
how much hot sauce does he have to eat
nothing you know what i mean come here
yeah chris show yourself come here get
out here
come here chris
have a little of dabong yeah
here chris
let's go
i deserve this yes you do for you leslie
okay
yeah
about damn time
[Laughter]
wait stay there stay here
wait wait wait wait just one second
let's just watch you for wait you can
freaking myself
for one second
we have to watch watch watch yeah watch
chris melt but he won't he is stoic he
is stoic there's one thing i know about
the guy
he's dying
fine
is it awful it's bad this is what you do
to people
[Laughter]
[Music]
you okay
yeah
here we go
do you have any questions
okay you can go
for later thank you
that's it for chris everybody
that made me feel so much better yeah me
too actually you know like that was long
overdue you know i'm happy that you did
that you know
me too
oh it just caught my throat i don't know
it has it just like it lives in there
yeah it does like living in the back of
my throat yeah and when i
i swallowed it it came back up again you
relive it again yeah
how are you doing back there yeah chris
how you doing are you dying
okay that's good
he end up smoking hot
i'd have to agree but i think after the
last one the bomb almost a walk in the
park
this is right spicy too yeah mm-hmm but
we're almost there there's a little dip
bomb left in there yeah like kind of
reactivates yeah
it's reactivating the bomb
what's the leslie man movie line that
gets yelled at you most in the wild
so many classics i'm very curious what's
at the top of the list um
um
let's get some [ __ ] french toast
i think it's that one
after that movie came out
a lot of girls come up to me and say
oh my gosh that's so me
and i'm like like what uh
uh driving and being crazy or whatever
that's so me i do that all the time
i'm like oh no
that's a bad idea don't do that
oh god
it just
got a little bomb
it's like in my throat
on the side first there you go
[Music]
oh
okay
cheers leslie what a ride okay cheers
[Music]
that's a spicy one that's a spicy one
but the good news is leslie man that
we're at the end of the road conquered
the hot ones gauntlet and just one more
question before we roll credits we're
gonna take it to your sweet spot which
is playfully ribbing your husband and
long time collaborator judd apatow to
close things out how do you think he
would fare against the wings of death
can you paint the picture for us in as
much detail as possible
that one's like really burny
[Music]
[Laughter]
oh that one's really really like that
one i don't like
these two are the worst
let the record show um
so
we went to a spice
restaurant and um
when we were traveling
um
that one's really bad i don't like that
one
um and he uh had
this whatever spicy food and um
and then
was having a margarita with it and he
went out to the car and passed out
he can't handle spice he would die
he would not be able to handle this but
you know who can handle it leslie mann
taking on the wings of death living to
tell the tale and now there's nothing
left to do but roll out the red carpet
for you this camera this camera this
camera let the people know what you have
going on in your life um what do i have
going on will you this yeah um i have
the bubble coming out april 1st which is
exciting
um
it's a really fun movie it's on netflix
and um uh
that's kind of it
thank you
good job oh my god
so fun
i was really nervous about it
what mod mod and i um watched the car
it's still burning
um
uh the
gordon ramsay episode she's like mom you
have to do it you have to do it
um
so that's why
i'm here but then i was really scared
and it's really burning still how long
does it take it's a diminishing return
situation so you'll be back okay
that was so fun though you had a good
time yes
thank you
yeah
thank you so guys really nice to meet
you tomorrow i said hi i will
can you fight chris
hey what's going on hot ones fans this
is sean evans checking in with a very
exciting announcement
we've read the comments we've seen the
emails and after six years more than 250
episodes we can now bring you the full
hot ones experience and one convenient
package i'm proud to introduce you to
hot ones boneless chicken bites
available exclusively at walmart and
walmart.com
each bag of hot ones boneless chicken
bites is packed with approximately 35
breaded seasoned white meat chicken
bites as well as individual packets of
the classic los calientes and the last
ab apollo for all your saucing and
dabbing needs the full hot ones
experience ready to heat and eat
whenever you get the craving to spice
things up at home hot ones boneless
chicken bites it's a party in a bag and
everyone's invited
[Music]
you